what it's like to be a teenager and you
know trying to figure out who you are
and really what he wants to do with his
life
Cameron voice was talented there's no
doubt about it but it's the way that he
carried himself and embraced to those
around him that was truly spectacular to
pay him tribute we put together a
timeline of Cameron's professional
career here's how Cameron became famous
and succeeded in giving us the best
childhoods of all time born to shine
before Cameron Boyce became Luke Ross on
Disney Channel's Jessie he was just a
normal kid growing up in Los Angeles
California Cameron was born on May 28
1999 it didn't take long for his talents
to bubble up which is why his parents
helped him follow his dreams from a very
young age
Cameron's love for the performing arts
became hard to ignore during his very
first talent show here the audience saw
with the world would soon find out
Cameron was a natural on stage his
devoted performance had every adult and
child in the audience on their feet
cheering with huge smiles on their faces
during a young Hollywood interview back
in 2015 a fan asked Cameron what he
would be doing with his life
if he'd never become a performer and
well Cameron just couldn't come up with
an answer in the end
Cameron was living his dream and
couldn't picture his life turning out
any other way than it did Cameron's
early life Cameron attended the Sherman
Oaks Center for enriched studies while
living at home with his parents Victor
and Libby Boyce and his younger sister
Maya living in Los Angeles made it
possible for Cameron's become a Disney
Channel star at a very young age in May
of 2018 Cameron made the decision to
move out of his parents home and become
roommates with his longtime friends
Sophie Reynolds and Karan Brar Cameron's
debut year Cameron's first role probably
isn't one you'd expect
as well it has nothing to do with the
Disney Channel back in 2008 when Cameron
was just nine years old he appeared in a
panic at the disco music video and that
same year Cameron upped his game by
landing the role of Michael Carson in
the horror movie mirrors which starred
Kiefer Sutherland Amy Smart and Paula
Patton but his debut year was far from
over in 2008 Cameron also played the
role of Sam Holloman in Eagle Eye which
starred household names like Shia
LaBeouf Billy Bob Jordan and Rosario
Dawson and choosing to finish his year
in good taste
a young Cameron landed the role of
Michael Kate's jr. in the hit TV drama
General Hospital night shift now that
has to be one of the most impressive
debut years of all time Cameron's family
supported him Cameron's parents always
took his dreams seriously they
encouraged him to follow his heart
be the best person he could be and to
let his passions lead the way without
their support it's possible that the
world would never have seen the
beautiful soul that was Cameron voice
Cameron had talents beyond doubts but he
also took great pride in helping others
and he credited his family for
cultivating his passion to help give
back according to Cameron there's a long
line of difference makers in his family
so he'd always known that he was
following in the footsteps of some
really strong men and women who showed
him wouldn't meant to give back Cameron
would never have become the man he was
without the love and support of his
amazing family Cameron becomes a Disney
star Cameron's life really began to
change when he landed the role of Luke
Ross on the hit TV series Jesse during
an interview with clever TV Cameron
opened up about how he found out that he
planned as a gig according to cam Jesse
star Debbie Ryan called his father's
phone asking to speak with him Cameron
wasn't shocked Debbie announced the good
news to Cameron once in the Disney
Channel database Cameron was able to
land a handful of other roles as well
grown-ups 1 & 2
but before Cameron became Luke Ross he
played Cathy Feder and grown
this hilarious movie gave Cameron the
exposure he needed while introducing him
to some of the biggest stars in
Hollywood Cameron appeared in grown-ups
in 2010 and in grown-ups too in 2013 he
was able to meet and work with Adam
Sandler and Salma Hayek who played his
on-screen parents after meeting Cameron
and vibing with him Adam Sandler asked
to appear on Jesse alongside his
on-screen son Adam finally made an
appearance in 2013 during the episode
titled punch dumps love Carlos Deville
when it came time to audition for
Disney's descendants Cameron already had
a very impressive portfolio so casting
him as Carlos Deville was a no-brainer
this sweet personality totally resonated
with Carlos making him the perfect guy
for the role
Carlos sang danced and acted his heart
out in descendants 1 & 2 and had
recently finished filming for
descendents 3 in 2018 during an
interview with young Hollywood Cameron
explains that playing Carlos on
descendants was the best job he ever had
you know I learned a lot and I had so
much fun and everybody was so amazing d3
is set to air on the Disney Channel on
August 2nd 2019 although watching Carlos
light up the screen will be better suite
fans cannot wait to see Cameron in his
element doing exactly what he was born
to do Cameron's last projects before
tragically passing away on July 6 2019
Cameron had been working on TV series
like mrs. Fletcher and Paradise City he
was also cast as Cal in the movie rent
Cameron was taken away before his time
the late star has left us with a
beautiful and compassionate legacy that
will warm our hearts forever
which one of Cameron's roles was your
favorites tell us in the comments we
personally can't choose between Luke
Ross and Carlos to go thanks for
watching the things we'll catch you next
time
[Music]